hi there my name is vic manana I play
Captain Kirk on Star Trek continues I
found out a few years ago actually that
the actual captain's chair was built
around an existing executive office
chair of the mid to late 60s it was the
Madison executive office chair so the
Star Trek designers being as brilliant
as they were rather than create
something from scratch took something
that existed and adapted it to make it
more futuristic and what they did was
they built what we would call this white
cradle at the Madison Citizen then when
you start detailing it you find that a
lot of the buttons that are on the
captain's chair are what we
affectionately refer to as gum drops
they're kind of translucent and they're
different colors you can't just find
these anywhere some of the people that
work with Star Trek continues actually
pour them make molds and pour them so
that we can have the right sizes because
of course if you look around the bridge
or actually probably anywhere around the
ship they're everywhere over here these
these are uh is a control panel that
Captain Kirk uses to do different things
for instance if I want to jettison the
ion pod let's say my old buddy Ben
Finney was in there we're not getting
along too well and I want to jettison
him boom he's gone data tapes another
very common image around the enterprise
Kirk's always got a few of them around
here I don't know what he's got on him
I'm not telling you what on mine but
they go right into this little tape slot
right here that's kind of fun if you
want to access some information blue
ones yellow ones Star Trek's all about
the primary colors and then of course
the standard intercom in the in the back
of the chair and you assemble this all
and you paint it just right by the way
this color is not white the actual color
is called gravity there's another little
interesting tidbit for you and when it's
all finished and completed you got
this you gotta lean back and you gotta
cross your legs because that's what
Captain Kirk would do for more
behind-the-scenes action of Star Trek
continues subscribe to the wired Channel